pour tenter d'apaiser la pénurie de main
d'oeuvre québec espère convaincre de
plus en plus de retraités de revenir sur
le marché du travail mais même si on
multiplie les incitatifs que certains
accommodements commence à se répandre on
peut encore faire mieux c'est ce que
conclut la chaire de recherche en
fiscalité et en finances publiques dans
sa plus récente étude est avec nous son
auteur luc godbout qui est titulaire de
la chaire merci beaucoup d'être là luc
alors d'abord important de rappeler les
projections démographiques nous montre
assez formellement la pénurie de main
d'oeuvre c'est un phénomène qui a pris
de l'ampleur qui n'est pas près de
disparaître et on est pris avec ça le
finalement qu'est-ce qu'on voit une
fenêtre avec plusieurs pour plusieurs
années ici quand même on le voit c'est
bien là les années 70 à ces années 80
les années 90 il serait ajouter beaucoup
de monde dans le bassin des 20 à 64 ans
les plus susceptibles de travailler les
serait juste et beaucoup de monde c'est
plus d'un million entre 71 et 91 600
mille personnes entre 91 et 2011 l'on
voit aussi s'en rajoute - c'est un peu
la courbe est moins dans les prochaines
décennies on en perd 90 milles dans le
bassin de 20 64 ans donc si on veut
créer des emplois ça faisait que faut
que ce soit des gens qui ont enlevé 64
ans qui ne travaillent pas qui rendent
le marché du travail ou que ce soit des
personnes or ces groupes-là qui décide
de revenir sur le marché du travail
parce qu'ils avaient pris de retraite
par exemple et là on pense donc aux
années c'est la raison
le pourquoi on devrait miser sur les les
travailleurs expérimentés qui sont de
retour au boulot ou les retraités c'est
sur eux qu'on doit miser en partie c'est
pas une solution unique mais c'est en
partie les aînés d'aujourd'hui sont en
meilleure santé que les années d'hier
ils sont plus nombreux aussi sont près
de l'est entre 60 et 69 ailleurs 1.2
millions personnes dans ce groupe d'âge
l'a donc en meilleure santé une
meilleure espérance de vie il y en a
déjà qui participent au marché du
travail mais quand on regarde avec
l'ontario tous nos groupes d'âge de 15 à
59 ans tous nos groupes d'âge on a des
meilleurs taux d'emploi que l'ontario
mais qu'on arrive aux 60 64 ou 65 69 ans
on a des taux plus bas ce qui laisse
penser que peut-être un peu de marge de
manoeuvre avec la persuasion avec
l'incitation je rappelle aussi que c'est
pas on veut pas changer l'âge de la
retraite est obligé le monde a travaillé
c'est vraiment volontaire sur une base
un statut ouais c'est ça parce que bon
il ya bien des gens dans ce groupe d'âge
là qui sont très confortables qui sont
très à l'aise d'être à la retraite mais
certains y pensent se demande je
pourrais y aller mais qu'est ce que ça
me donnerait réellement je pense que
c'est ça la grande question est ce que
c'est rentable en fait de retourner au
travail quand on est déjà à la retraite
et des pistes de solution les alouettes
se fait petit bout pour un aînés à
faible revenu par exemple ça va
augmenter son niveau de vie on se fond
ont tous deux la question c'est
quelqu'un qui gagne à peine 21 e mail de
prestations publiques ne n'a pas de réel
n'y a pas de régime privé ton employeur
il gagne 21 me de revenus et décide
d'aller travailler pour gagner dix mille
de plus donc ils étaient faibles revenus
il va perdre vous c'est vrai 1656
dollars de son supplément de revenu
garanti vaut payer un peu plus au régime
d'assurance médicaments va payer des
cotisations salariales sociales sur son
salaire mais payent pas d'impôts au
crédit de prolongation de carrière
s'applique à tchité va donc y conserve
73% de son 10000 dollars tant qu'on
travaille pas pour rien qu'on veuille
pas pouvoir y est et à 21000 pensée de
21000 à 29 me de revenus disponibles ou
de 22 à 30 environ de bain une sacrée
augmentation de son niveau de vie c'est
là que le paisible actions et le petit
luxe devient plus facile à se procurer
donc pour ceux qui le souhaitent
toujours qui on peut le faire maintenant
aussi pour des gens à revenus plus moyen
ou à revenus plus élevés et on
peut le voir sur le prochain tableau en
fait mon le 73 % de taux de conservation
de revenus on le retrouve ici mon
tableau à votre gauche donc pour
quelqu'un qui a un revenu de retraite
vous le disiez s'embrassent un régime
d'employeur ou autre donc toute
conservation des revenus 73,2 %
lorsqu'on voit c'est que quand le revenu
du travail augmente ou encore que le
revenu de retraite eux demandent qu'est
ce qu'on voit le mais on voit qu'on
premièrement conserve toujours un taux
de conservation du revenu de travail
qu'on va chercher une fois la retraite
plus élevée que 50 pouces donc si on
même si qu'on gagne 60 3 me de revenus
de prêts verts de retraite et qu'on va
chercher 30000 de revenus de travail
concernant sa 95000 de revenir pour être
quand même pas rien si l'on fait partie
assurément des 10% à la retraite et avec
les revenus les plus élevés on conserve
quand même 57% de notre 30000 qu'on va
chercher un revenu de travail donc
l'exercice qu'on cherchait à faire ici
s'est montrée peut-être qu'on en
conservant un peu plus qu'on ne le
pensait et donc c'est un peu plus
rentable qu'on ne le souhaitait et que
des mythes peut-être un peu d'audace ou
dans le passé les gens se faisaient dire
que cet apport à une table de rester qui
est peut-être allé un peu plus
présentement par par des efforts des
gouvernements aussi le mois le plus que
vous êtes là aujourd'hui pour nous
l'expliquer tout ça mais ce que les gens
sont au courant c'est ça le problème c
est ce que ils ont les connaissances
pour analyser leur situation est ce que
j'y retourne quel sera l'impact sur mes
cotisations sur mes impôts est-ce que
les gens sont bien outillés pour faire
ce calcul
depuis le monde cet hiver ils sont bien
outillés encore possible de savoir mais
sur le site du ministère des finances du
québec dans un onglet qui s'appelle
outil on peut aller voir revenu de
retraite revenu de travail à la retraite
et on rentre notre âge large de notre
conjoint le revenu qu'on a de retraite
de revenus qu'on voudrait les faire sur
le marché du travail et bling ça nous
donne aux bretons qu'on va conserver
encore faut-il savoir où est donc pour
publiciser ce lien là on le mettra sur
notre lâchent ils se trouvaient puis
avec ça les gens au pouvoir plus
facilement prendre une décision éclairée
bon donc puisqu'on a conclu que dans
tous les cas on en a plus dans nos
poches lorsqu'on retourne au travail à
la rhett qu'est-ce qu'on peut amener
comme argument pour convaincre les
années de revenir travailler qu'est-ce
qu'on peut amener comme arguments pour
les convaincre
les arguments pour les convaincre c'est
quand même c'est juste de faire
l'exercice est de voir s'il en reste six
ans reste est proposé mais des
plantations c'est plus pour le
gouvernement c'est pour le gouvernement
pour ce qu'on peut en donner encore un
peu plus aux aînés puis un argument le
plus courant depuis que les légendes
dans ce secteur là commence à en parler
ça serait de type de rendre facultative
les cotisations au régime de retraite
des régimes des rentes à 65 ans dans le
reste du canada c'est comme ça ici c'est
une obligation donc le rendre facultatif
laisser le choix aux gens de savoir
s'ils cotisent ou non si l'europe sont
bonifiés ou s'ils conservent l'argent
dans les poches qui accroîtrait encore
une fois le revenu de travail à la
retraite godbout merci beaucoup pour vos
explications très claires le patois
merci pour voir nos émissions en entier
rendez vous sur la chaîne ici et redit
[Musique]